[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hahlweg
guten Abend und willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem Samstag
die vom Sport hat Norbert Lehmann und
das sind die wichtigsten Themen von
heute
wachsende Sorge vor der Omi konnte die
Gesundheitsminister der Länder fordern
vom
Reise
in der Türkei
[Musik]
das im Tempo steigt die Inzidenzen gehen
im Moment leicht zurück das hätten
positive Entwicklungen an diesem vierten
Adventswochenende sein können wenn da
nicht die Omikron Variante wäre die
Prognosen der Experten sind beklemmend
die Gesundheitsminister der Länder
plädierten heute in einer sonder schalte
dafür Großbritannien schnell zum Virus
Varianten Gebiet zu erklären um die
Omikron Welle wenigstens abzubremsen
Alexandra Vacano hat details
Lichtershow und laute Beat inklusive
boosterimpfung im Auto und das zwei Tage
rund um die Uhr hier an der Messe
Stuttgart währenddessen aber wächst die
Sorge vor der nächsten Infektionswelle
mit der neuen Corona Variante Omikron
wird man auf jeden Fall eine Dominanz
jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
sehr sehr kurzer Zeit haben also z.b. zu
Weihnachten das dann Omikron schon
dominiert es könnte jetzt also schnell
gehen das dürfte auch die Lage an den
Kliniken noch einmal deutlich
verschärfen seit Oktober gibt es wieder
einen steilen Anstieg bei den
Patientinnen und Patienten auf deutschen
Intensivstationen
aktuell sind es
wenn sich die Prognose aus anderen
Ländern bestätigen müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass wir in der nächsten Welle
vielmehr gleichzeitig schwer erkrankte
Menschen haben die dann notwendigerweise
die Krankenhäuser aufsuchen müssen das
heißt Mehrbelastung Mehrbelegung weniger
Kapazitäten für andere Patienten Omikron
kann auch geimpfte treffen ist sehr
ansteckend und kann sich schnell
ausbreiten im gleichzeitig viele
Millionen Menschen krank werden nicht
dass wir hospitalisiert werden müssen
aber zu Hause bleiben müssen Quarantäne
sind bedeutet das ja dass sie überall
fehlen also in der kritischen
Infrastruktur im Pflegebereich in den
Krankenhäusern in den Schulen in bei der
Polizei wenige Tage vor Weihnachten
wächst also die Sorge vor Omikron die
Länder wollen die Ausbreitung
verlangsamen
deswegen war es noch mal wichtig
deswegen gemeinsamen Beschluss gefasst
haben und das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium
aufgefordert haben sich dafür
einzusetzen dass Großbritannien Virus
Varianten Gebiet wird und dass man vor
der Einreise einen PCR Test braucht für
die Politik gilt es nun die neue Welle
zu verzögern zu verhindern ist sie wohl
nicht
bislang gelten 8 starten im südlichen
Afrika als Virus Varianten Gebiete
Großbritannien wäre das erste in Europa
diese von dort durften dann nur noch
deutsche oder in Deutschland lebende
Personen hier einreisen als Schutz zwei
sich in Großbritannien die onikon
Variante eben rasend schnell verbreitet
die Stadt London hat deswegen heute den
Katastrophenfall ausgerufen über die
Lage vor Ort berichtet Andreas Stamm
der Blick in eine Postfiliale genügt um
zu erahnen was los ist Corona teststadt
Weihnachtsbriefe bringen das
Verteilsystem an den Rand des
Zusammenbruchs der drohe auch den
Krankenhäusern wegen Omicron wenn ich
schnell gehandelt werde Kontakt
Beschränkungen etwa was Treffen in
Innenräumen angehe so die
wissenschaftlichen Berater der Regierung
was am wichtigsten ist dass wir noch
mehr Menschen impfen die haben es
schleifen lassen und nun reicht es nicht
wir könnten uns im Januar in einer
furchtbaren Situation wiederfinden
entscheiden werde sein ob Omikron Melder
Verlaufe oder nicht die Regierung hat
zwar das Booster Programm hochgefahren
mehr als 800 000 Nadelstiche am Tag doch
zu wenig so die Experten solange
Veranstaltungen die die Dart WM weiter
liefen oder volle Stadion bei
Fußballspielen und genau in der Premier
League zeigt sich wie schnell Omikron
sich verbreitet wegen zuvielen
erkrankten Spielern wurden jetzt sechs
von zehn wochenendparty NAB sagt für
London den Omegon Hotspot trägt der
Bürgermeister am Nachmittag den
Katastrophenfall aus
die Zahl der Krankenhauseinweisung
um die onikon Variante einzudämmen
verschafft Österreich seine
einreiseregeln ab Montag dürfen nur noch
geimpfte und gelesene ins Land da keine
Auffrischimpfung hat muss zusätzlich
einen aktuellen PC Attest vorlegen die
neuen Regeln durften auch viele deutsche
Skiurlauber treffen die in den kommenden
Wochen nach Österreich wollen die
aktuellen Corona Zahlen in Deutschland
sehen so aus
42813 Neuinfektionen wurden im Robert
Koch Institut binnen 24 Stunden gemeldet
10884 weniger als am vergangenen Samstag
414 Todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
Tages dazu die sieben Tage Inzidenz
sinkt auf nun 300
21,8
Bundestagspräsidentin was von der SPD
fordert ein nationales impfregister die
Gesundheitsämter wüssten weder konkret
wie viele Infektionen es gibt noch den
genauen Stand bei den Impfungen visierte
sie in der Welt am Sonntag ein zentrales
Register mit den Daten der geimpften
könnte auch Voraussetzung für die
Einführung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
sein spd-generalsekretär Kühnert lehnt
dagegen die allgemeine Impfpflicht ab es
seien noch ganz viele schwierige
juristische Fragen zu klären sagte er
dem redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
gegen die Corona Maßnahmen und eine
mögliche Impfpflicht sind in mehreren
deutschen Städten heute wieder tausende
auf die Straße gegangen die meisten
kamen in Hamburg zusammen unter dem
Motto das Maß ist voll hände weg von
unseren Kindern sind dort nach
Schätzungen der Polizei mehr als 11.000
demonstrierende unterwegs Jusos die
Grüne Jugend und linke Gruppen haben
eine Gegendemo organisiert für alle gilt
eine Masken Pflicht bis auf kleinere
Auseinandersetzungen sind ist bislang
täglich auch in Bayern verliefen
Proteste ohne gravierende zwischen Zelle
in Bamberg versammelten sich rund 1600
Menschen dreimal mehr als angemeldet
die große Mehrheit ist geimpft und
versucht auch sich so zu verhalten dass
das Virus möglichst wenig schoss zur
Verbreitung bekommt nur wie geht das am
besten über die Feiertage Elisabeth
Schmidt hat sich umgehört
und sie haben ihre Firmenparty einfach
nach draußen verlegt
Abstand Frischluft Vorsicht schon wieder
Corona Weihnachten und Pandemie
angepasste Festtags Pläne wir werden
das ist sehr schade
einigermaßen gut biege
komme ich dann sogar auf weniger als 1%
nämlich fast auf 1 Promille damit die
Maske richtig setzt empfiehlt der
Forscher sie zu einem weh zu falten
dadurch entweicht an der Nase weniger
Atemluft hier rechts im Bild bei treffen
ohne Maske raten Infektiologen vorher
einen Antigen Schnelltest machen das
gilt auch für geimpfte
der schnellheft macht das endlich keinen
Unterschied zwischen symptomatisch und
aromatisch weil sie Viruslast ist
unabhängig von den Symptomen und den
besten macht man den Schnelltest täglich
und
kombiniert eben mit entsprechenden
Hygieneregeln also Abstand halten
regelmäßig lüften testen impfen damit
sich mit der Weihnachtsstimmung nicht
auch das Virus verbreitet
die Türkei belastet zusätzlich zur
Corona Pandemie noch eine tiefe
Wirtschaftskrise die Landeswährung Lira
stürzt immer weiter ab in den
vergangenen vier Wochen verlor 7 massiv
an Wert 1 Lira ist heute nur noch etwas
mehr als fünf Cent wert das ist ein
Einbruch von mehr als 30% diese Teuerung
treibt immer mehr Menschen in die Armut
Jörg Brase berichtet
zurzeit rund 230 € der Präsident hofft
die Lage dadurch entschärfen
ich hoffe dass der neue Mindestlohn den
Arbeitnehmern Glück bringen wird wir
werden nicht zulassen dass unsere
Arbeitnehmer unter den steigenden
Preisen erdrückt werden
der Präsident
wenn es so kommt wird die Finanzspritze
der Regierung nur kurze Erholung bringen
werden viele vor der staatlichen Brot
Ausgabe weiter Schlange stehen
auf den Philippinen sind durch Taifun
Rey mindestens 31 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen besonders im Süden und in der
Mitte des Inselstaates wurden Häuser
zerstört es kam zu Überschwemmungen mehr
als 18.000 Rettungskräfte waren im
Einsatz und Bewohner in Sicherheit zu
bringen mittlerweile hat der Tropensturm
die Philippinen wieder verlassen
wenn eine Katastrophe plötzlich alles
verändert viele Menschen in Stolberg
wissen genau was das bedeutet
die Stadt mit mehr als 56000 Einwohnern
liegt im Großraum Aachen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
sie wurde mit am schlimmsten von dem
verheerenden Hochwasser im Juli
getroffen wie die Stollberger 5 Monate
danach die Vorweihnachtszeit erleben
zeigt jenacon
über 3m hoch stand das Wasser in
Stolberg zerstörte viele Straßen
Geschäfte und Mietwohnungen hier stand
der Keller unter Wasser mittlerweile
zieht der Schimmel in die oberen
Stockwerke
Folgeschäden der Flut mit denen bis
heute viele Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
zu kämpfen haben kein warmes Wasser
manchmal haben wir auch keinen Strom
keine Heizung den Kindern die Kinder
weinen manchmal vor Kälte wie lange man
meist zu frei manchmal wollen die nicht
duschen der Wideraufbau läuft nur sehr
schleppend beklagt Chris Lemmon von der
Bürgerinitiative
freiwillige Helferinnen und Helfer die
gespendete Hilfsgüter sammeln und an
Flutopfer verteilen
ihren wir haben eben
Migrationshintergründe wir haben ja
soziale Brennpunkte wir haben wirklich
diese Ängste der Menschen sicher zu
artikulieren sei es durch dass sie Games
sind dass sie sich nicht trauen die
meisten Betroffenen warten immer noch
auf staatliche Hilfsgelder und auch die
allgemeine Bereitschaft zu helfen lässt
in Stolberg immer mehr nach etwas
natürlich auch die Menschen sehr betrübt
macht weil es am Anfang sehr sehr
schnell ging da wurde sehr viel geholfen
mit Nachbarn mit Freunden mit bekannten
aber jetzt wo man das Geld braucht und
wo man die Handwerker braucht draut
dauert es halt sehr lange und das ist
natürlich etwas was jetzt nicht wirklich
zur Weihnachtsstimmung beiträgt ein
Weihnachtsfest das für die Flutopfer
aber auch für ganz Stolberg von den
Folgen der Flut überschattet bleibt
sollte nicht so sein jetzt sind wir beim
Wintersport und ein wieder sehr
erfolgreichen Skispringer und sehr
nerven starken Skispringer Karl Geiger
mein zweiter Weltcup-Sieg in dieser
Saison bei der Generalprobe für die
Vierschanzentournee das Sprenger im
schweizerischen Engelberg nerven stark
eben auf den ersten Platz und verteidige
damit auch seine Führung in der Weltcup
Gesamtwertung
ein Wort das alles aussagt Karl Geiger
nähert sich 10 Tage vor Beginn der
Vierschanzentournee seiner besten Form
bin sehr glücklich über den Weg kommt
heute das war mal wichtig für mich dass
das so weil er hat immer versucht zu
faxen und die letzten Wochen nicht ganz
so gut gelungen in Engelberg
[Musik]
in Altenberg wie ist der 31-Jährige im
Zweierbob Weltcup Wettbewerb nicht
anbrennen und bleibt in dieser Saison
ungeschlagen zusammen mit Thorsten
Margis siegte er vor dem deutschen du
Christoph Hafer und ist am Amur
und ebenfalls eine starke Leistung
zeigte heute der Nordische Kombinierer
Vinzenz Geiger beim Weltcup in Ramsau
erkämpfte er im Männer Einzelwettbewerb
den zweiten Platz hinter Weltmeister
Jarl Magnus riiber aus Norwegen
letzte Hinrundenspiel Tag in der
Fußballbundesliga Mannschaft der Stunde
ist Eintracht Frankfurt der sechste Sieg
in den letzten sieben Spielen heute im
Rheinhessen Derby gegen Mainz hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse
die Eintracht gewinnt knapp aber
verdient mit eins zu null Überraschung
in Leipzig RB verliebt verliert gegen
Bielefeld mit 0 zu 2 Fürth und Augsburg
trennen sich torlos Bochum unterliegt
Union Berlin mit nur zu eins Hoffenheim
Gladbach Spiel unentschieden eins zu
eins das Abendspiel Hertha BSC gegen
Borussia Dortmund bereits gestern
besiegte Bayern die Wolfsburger mit 14
die Tabelle Bayern Herbstmeister
Dortmund 2. könnte den Abstand auf
München heute Abend wieder verkürzen
Leverkusen 3. Hoffenheim 4. Jörn
Frankfurt springt auf Platz fünf die
zweite Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit Köln
Wolfsburg nach der fünften Liga
Niederlage in Folge 12 und am Ende
Stuttgart Bielefeld und abgeschlagen
führt letzter
das Abendspiel Hertha gegen Dortmund
ausführlich zu sehen bei uns im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu Gast
bei Dunja Hayali Tennis Olympiasieger
Alexander Zverev
Isabel Gose hat die erste deutsche
Medaille bei der Kurzbahn WM in Abu
Dhabi nur knapp verpasst die 19-Jährige
aus Magdeburg Flug im Finale über 800
Meter FreiSpiel als vierte an mit nur
knapp 13 Sekunden Rückstand auf Bronze
Gold holte überlegen die Chinese in
Liebing DJ
und das was von Sport
schon heute eine Bescherung gab es für
einen Lotto Glückspilz aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen für ihn oder sie
schneit der EuroJackpot in 1073, sieben
Millionen Euro dafür könnte man z.b.
zwei neue ICS kaufen und von den
verbleibenden sechs Millionen Euro diese
Seite nur um zu schauen ob sie auch
pünktlich sind oder diesen van Gogh auch
da wären noch zwei Millionen übrig für
etwas ums Kunstwerk rum etwa eine Villa
mit Alarmanlage
allerdings wusste ja schon Zähne car
Geld hat noch keinen reich gemacht in
den nächsten Tagen wird es kälter mehr
dazu hat gleich ausdehnt Erliegen das
heute journal um 10:45 Uhr mit Claus
Kleber wir danken für Ihr Interesse und
wünschen Ihnen noch ein schönes
Wochenende bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die tief sind sie
auf einer etwas ungewöhnlichen Zugbahn
dieses hier zieht von Nord nach Süd und
lenkt dabei kühlere Luft südwärts und
dir reicht uns teilweise auch aber
schauen Sie hier auf dem Atlantik hier
erreicht Warmluft teilweise Grönland in
den nächsten Tagen und sogar bis in die
Arktis wird diese warme Luft hin
verfrachtet lehnartz gibt es einige
Wolken nach Osten in unter regnet es
sonst sind die Wolken dicht und im Süden
lockert es teilweise auf ist bildet sich
Nebel Temperaturen dort bis -7° plus 7
Grad im Nordwesten Deutschlands morgen
Tagesverlauf im Osten Deutschlands
kompakte Wolken mit Regen dieser Ring
zieht allmählich suedes voran sonst im
Süden Sonnenschein und im Norden auch
und der Wind ist teilweise Streit aus
nordwestlichen Richtungen Temperaturen
dazu maximal 1 Grad am Alpenrand und 9
Grad im Nordwesten Deutschlands die
kommenden Tage
etwas Schnee Richtung Berchtesgadener
Land am Montag sonst ist es trocken die
Sonne scheint verbreitet vor allem im
Nordwesten - 1 bis 7 Grad und die darauf
folgenden Tage die werden vor allem
allmählich Kühler mit -2 bis 5 Grad ein
schöner Abend